Which x values ​​make the ordered pair
x Semi - Minus 2 System Solution
inequalities presented in the graph below?
So let's look at it.
We are limited to all points
of the x-type minus 2,
which is another way to say it will
we limit to equal to minus 2.
If we limit to less than 2,
what should be true for x to be this point
solution of this system of inequalities?
I recommend that you pause the video,
take a look at this chart here and then choose one of the answers.
Okay, now let's do it together.
Just let us know what we have here.
I will choose a few points.
This point here, it is not a solution of
none of the inequalities in the system.
You can see this as the green system
and this as the blue system.
To be in the multitude of decisions, we must be
in the colored area for this system.
So this point here is not in the multitude of decisions
for none of the inequalities in the system.
This point here,
it will also not be in the multitude of decisions for any of them,
because it lies on the broken green line.
If it was a solid green line, then it would be part of it
of the green set of solutions, but since the green line is interrupted,
the right itself is not part of the decisions.
Now, this point here,
this point satisfies the green inequality,
it is part of his multitude of decisions,
but does not satisfy blue inequality,
so it's not from the multitude of system solutions.
Now this point here, it will actually satisfy both
and the reason to satisfy them both,
it is clear that she is in the colored area for green inequality,
but it lies on the rights of blue inequality,
but that's good because we include the rights itself
in the multitude of decisions;
this is a dense blue line.
So this point will be in the set of solutions for
the system of inequalities;
this will be in the set of solutions for
the system of inequalities, all these points,
because they are in the multitude of the decisions of the blue inequality,
which we see in the green.
We assume that the green just goes down.
And in fact what we see here
is actually overlapping.
Now that we understand things better,
let us actually answer the questions.
We are limited to equal to minus 2.
Actually, let me draw a right here that shows everyone
points in which y is equal to minus 2.
This shows, at least on the graph,
where y is equal to minus 2.
Given that equals to minus 2, what should be true for x,
to satisfy the inequality system here?
Well we're going to deal with all the x values,
to the right and including this point.
I can also say, because the blue inequality,
we can also have equal points of rights;
we can actually be right.
Finding rights, we will be part of the set of solutions for both
or all that is right.
So that's all
is part of the set of solutions.
And thus, if we limit y to be equal to minus 2,
we see that x should be greater than
or equal to minus 3.
And we see that
this is this answer,
this answer is there,
x is greater than or equal to minus 3.
Now let's resolve another, instead of limiting y,
now we will limit x.
Which value of y will make the ordered 4-digit pair y
solution of the system of inequalities presented
through the graph below?
Again, I recommend that you pause the video
and see if you can do it yourself.
Okay, now let's do it together.
In this case, we restrict x.
We say x must be equal to 4.
So, x equal to 4,
these are all points of this right
right here.
We are limited to points,
but we want to be part of it
of the multitude of decisions.
So we want to be on this right,
which limits us to a value equal to 4,
but we want to be in the area of ​​overlapping sets of solutions
of the two inequalities to satisfy the system.
So let's see.
We want to be in this area here,
this is the overlap of sets of decisions
of the two inequalities.
And thus, if we limit to x equal to 4,
y should be larger than, because we do not include
the green line itself, it is interrupted.
So u must be greater than minus 1
or we can say minus 1 should be less than y,
and then u can have values ​​only
up to 3 inclusive.
Up up to 3 including this blue line
is actually dense.
So everything that's on the blue line
will be in the multitude of the decisions of the blue inequality.
And this point I show here is definitely
is located in the area of ​​overlap of the two inequalities,
so u should be less than or equal to 3.
Therefore, if x is equal to 4, y should be
greater than minus 1 or less
or equal to minus 3 ...
And less than or equal to 3, I had to say.
Let's see which of these answers:
minus 1 is less than y, is less than or equal to 3.
This is, once again, the first answer.